jceline Antoine pour le groupe de
l'Union
[Applaudissements]
centriste monsieur le Président Mesdames
et messieurs les ministres madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur
fen il n'a pas pu vous
échapper que depuis le début de la
semaine de nombreux panneaux d'entrée de
nos communes sont retrouvés à l'envers
et oui
ou
échanger le message est clair on marche
sur la tête ce sont les jeunes
agriculteurs de nos départements qui
nous le disent l'action est peut-être
anecdotique mais leur combat les moins
les agriculteurs ont engagé une
transition dans leurs exploitations une
transition pour le renouvellement des
générations une transition énergétique
une transition environnementale pourtant
on continue de faire pression sur leur
prix ce n'est pas une pression que nos
agriculteurs souhaitent mais une vision
monsieur le ministre et la vôtre manque
clairement d'ambition la politique
agricole du gouvernement est incohérente
vous imposez le respect des normes aux
agriculteurs alors même que la plupart
des produits importés n'y répondent pas
la coupe est pleine le monde agricole
exprime son
exaspération et pourtant c'est encore
avec des actions syndicales
respectueuses des biens et des personnes
que les agriculteurs nous alertent cette
semaine alors Monsieur le Ministre ma
question est simple quelle mesure
durable et connecté à la réalité de
terrain allez-vous prendre pour redonner
du souffle de la compétitivité et de
l'espoir à nos
agriculteurs merci pour vous répondre la
parole est au ministre de l'agriculture
et la souveraineté alimentaire monsieur
Marc fot vous avez la
parole président merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice
ce n'est pas une action anecdotique elle
vient interpeller le gouvernement vient
tous nous interpellerer sur la
trajectoire que nous voulons alors vous
demandez qu'on vous réponde sur la
question de quelle est la trajectoire et
quels sont les objectifs alors au cas
vous ne les ayez pas discerné d'abord la
première objectif c'est un objectif de
rémunération c'est les lois égalim 1
égalim 2 les lois la loi des cusailles
qui a été voté dans vos dans les deux
assemblées qui ont permis de travailler
sur la rémunération même s'il y a des
progrès à faire je ne croiserai pas un
agriculteur vous ne croiserez pas un
agriculteur qui disent qu'il Fass
supprimer ses lois faut aller plus loin
mais on sait sur un certain nombre de
produits la question la rémunération est
importante le deuxième sujet pour vous
donner des éléments concrets parce que
j'ai l'impression que vous en manquiez
sur la question des assurances nous
avons voqué nous avons voté vous avez
voté à l'Assemblée nationale et ici au
Sénat un texte qui vient profondément
modifié qui vient profondément modifier
le système assurentiel et qui vient
garantir la résilience du système puis
après il faut qu'on ait un cap le cap
qu'on a c'est le cap de la souveraineté
et le câ de la transition parce qu'il y
aura pas l'un sans l'autre pour que nous
puissions assumer la souveraineté on a
besoin d'assumer aussi des transition i
en particulier celle lié au dérèglement
climatiqu pour ça nous avons un outil
qui a été travaillé avec les
professionnels agricoles qui est celui
de la planification nous avons besoin de
planification pour voir si les
injonctions que nous souhaitons les
objectifs d'augmentation de production
de biomasse de souveraineté alimentaire
peuvent permettre de répondre aux autres
injonctions que nous avons sur l'eau sur
les produits phytosanitaires ça c'est
les objets de planification puis
troisème sujet pour être crédible nous
avons besoin de moyen et ça c'est le
budget que vous examinerez prochainement
c'est plus d' 1,3 milliard d'euros sur
la l' année 2024 c'est un budget sans
précédent en terme d'augmentation et
sans précédent en terme de montant donc
une trajectoire une planification des
moyens financiers par ailleurs vous vous
avez évoqué la question du pacte et la
loi de l'orientation c'est dans le cadre
de ce pacte de cette loi d'orientation
que tout ça sera combiné pour mettre de
la cohérence et pour montrer la
cohérence de notre action et la première
la première ministre aura l'occasion de
le faire dans les prochaines semaines
voilà la sénatrice que je voulais vous
dire Madame
Antoine
merci Monsieur le Ministre j'entends
votre réponse l'ensemble des mesures que
vous évoquez ne répond pas complètement
à l'enjeux des prix du partage et de la
valeur ajoutée et nos paysans souffrent
dans nos
campagnes merci